[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est notre invité du jour c'est notre
échec une adepte d'une journée mystère
du jour il est magnifié et romans merci
d'être là en tout cas je suis très
heureux que tu sois venu parce que je
suis admiratif de ce que tu fais de ce
que tu as fait alors est-ce que c'est
l'actualité heureuse c'est d'actualité
heureuse un oui on peut poser des
questions et bien sûr dans son époque
est ce qu'à un grand sportif oui oui oui
est ce que tu penses que cyril est
meilleur que toi dans ce sport là que tu
as un nom original dans ce sport là un
don non c'est de l'entraînement il avait
essayé de faire un sport qui joue avec
le plie ou avec une raquette
aucun des deux merde est-ce quelqu'un
d'autre question d appel à vous pensez
merci à le kamikaze est un sport
collectif
ça dépend mais le plus souvent bon
d'accord pas quoi parce que c'est un
sport de vitesse
oui ça peut s'appeler très bon que tu as
gagné un trophée par rapport à ça non on
aurait trop fait il a 13 ans s'appelle
christophe cette mesure 1 m 40 c'est ça
quatre bandits
[Applaudissements]
fidéle âge et je vous dis il a trente
médailles d'or 40 médailles d'argent
ah ouais 25 médailles de bronze est ce
que c'est un don qui va être apportée
pendant seulement de l'argent l'argent
non parfois ses membres n'ont pas si tu
travailles avec moi j'étais très jeune
est ce que c'est un sport où on atteint
son talent majeur à 13 ans ou est ce que
tu es jeune pour ton sport alors ça
dépend si c'est pour le long à mon âge
c'est bon pour ma taille plutôt si c'est
pour la vitesse c'est plus de la galette
ouais il a fait quelque chose
d'incroyable je vous dis si vous
n'auriez vous allez halluciner
nous ici on et personne n'est capable de
le faire autour de la table jusqu'au
choix est ce que tu penses que tu peux
encore progresser où tu étais au mcs de
toi oui je n'ai pas encore progressé à
huawei est ce que c'est vrai bien
reconnu genre qui aux jeux olympiques
est tout ouïe ouïe et s'est déjà trouvé
le sport et ses troubles csk vélo dans
le sport oui
donc est ce que tu es naja oui voilà oui
alors attendez parce que ce qu'il a fait
c'est non oui bravo frédéric à deux
questions celle que tu mets un casque un
casque si on n'a pas si nous la paix
comme ça c'est un bonnet dans l'eau un
bonnet web
j'ai raté ma laissé la seule qui choque
et aka jeunesse un peu sa variante au
matos et sa mère si jamais on sait
jamais où c'est le wigig puisque dans le
cadre de la natation c'est plutôt du
sprint où il faut aller très vite
non non bernard montiel est ce que tu
aurais pu faire encore plus que ce que
tu as fait non non jean-michel traverser
le oui est ce que l'eau était chaude où
l'eau était froide
non alors oui frédéric la traversée de
la manche
non non non c'est pas bien c'était dans
une piscine où c'était on est là en mer
en mer bref ce qu'on peut donner la
réponse comme en asie moisi qui sait je
crois que c'est le petit bonhomme qui a
traversé aux antilles 40 km qu'à nager
plus de 40 km ah ça oui c'est ça
ce qu'il a fait est là hilali 13 heures
50 minutes et 47 secondes c'est le temps
qu'il a fallu à christophe pour nager 40
km et revoir la martinique depuis l'île
de sainte-lucie samedi dernier cette
action il n'a pas fait pour rien il l'a
fait pourquoi
dis-nous christophe pour une bonne cause
c'est chasser la lutte contre la cancer
et que nous ayons on va on va regarder
le sujet regardez c'est énorme ce qu'il
a fait christian et bravo dengue est une
bombe regardent en chien qu'on se le
dise il ne fait aucun doute que ce jeune
garçon est bel et bien un héros il a
tout donné ils avancent au mental en
plus d'un exploit physique intense il a
fait ça pour la bonne cause
pourquoi pas tenter un défi pour les
femmes atteintes du tiers dans le cadre
d'octobre rose le mouvement de
sensibilisation pour lutter contre le
cancer du sein à 12 ans christophe malo
a décidé de rejoindre à la nage l'état
insulaire de sainte lucie et la
martinique 13 heures 50 minutes et 47
secondes dans la mer une distance de
plus de 40 km une rage qui s'explique en
partie par le fait que sa propre mère a
été victime de cette maladie le soir
christophe est avec nous pour tout nous
raconter de son exploit
[Musique]
annie vide christophe vous rendez compte
il a nagé 13 entités pas fatigué moi
j'ai moi même mais je marche 13h cheval
un trésor mois c'est le temps qu'il me
faut pour mettre mes yeux alors tu l'as
fait pour ta maman qui était atteinte
d'un cancer
tu l'as fait pour être comme on a eu
cette idée mais en fait tu es un certain
gilles rondi thiam a réalisé sa petite
martinique justement pas et j'avais déjà
nagé le dernier kilomètre avec nous
d'accord et tu te dis dans les 40
mais je me souviens comme jane bang
quand j'avais 9 ans à l'époque
donc comme la n 9 ans je vais faire un
peu moins et juste après j'ai découvert
que ma mère était atteinte d'un cancer
du sein et du coup je voulais montrer
qu'il fallait se battre contre la
maladie et du coup j'ai réussi leur
premier défi qui était de traverser la
baie de fort-de-france
c'était 5 km j'amène est bon magnifique
alors lambert ta maman elle doit
forcément faire des toiles très fière de
toi mais je l'espère je l'espère et ben
regarde parce que ta maman elle a un
petit message pourquoi en garde mon
chien talus des sox et maman de la
martinie tony deuxième temps je tenais à
te dire que je t'aime beaucoup de suis
fier de toi merci d'avoir fait prendre
conscience aux familles palestiniennes
plus tôt et merci pour la lui qu'on peut
pas faire quand tu mènes que tu as menée
car pouvait
en ce matin on pouvait y arriver je
t'aime trop et je te laissant toute la
famille terre que la main
ému de voir ta maman oui
arias ton papa kenya coach sait que
c'est son entraîneur et je voulais dire
que ce que tu as fait c'est exceptionnel
et vraiment on voulait que tu sois dans
l'émission aujourd'hui surtout
aujourd'hui où parce que voilà c'est ça
voilà c'est magnifique de voir des
actions comme ça et est à 12 ans je sais
que ton rêve se regarde et je serais
champion olympique c'est mal et je suis
sûr que tu vas y arriver
j'espère que tu verras on verra plus
tard on verra les images d'hier a
regardé c'était champions l'as ptt sa
première télé c'était ici et au profit
de christophe ballot c'est ton baba d un
sétois michaud et ont failli aggraver
touba non c'est la mère sonia jean
baptiste et doivent aller exactement et
tu veux être champion olympique donc
moins de temps mais j'aimerais juste
pour représenter la france aux jo mais
bon mécano à bercy mais c'est cadeau est
ce que tu es le meilleur de tournage
aujourd'hui
alors ça dépend sur canal j'accorde tu
vas faire quelle distance c'est quoi tu
veux être champion olympique sur quelles
distances en voiture je l'étais pas
une truc débile et comment est-ce que tu
as mangé dans la mer alors c'est vrai
bonne question
il mangeait des poissons il passait le
barrage tranquille alors ouais je ne
mange pas enfin j'veux pas ce qu'attend
et comment qu'a fait d'être en saucisson
de succession comme son sacre à vis de
toi dans ton mayotte avait trop de
social est certaine il sortait de son
studio
je voudrais qu'on applaudisse très fort
qui sort
[Applaudissements]